[Música]
esta es ama ya tiene 82 años todas las
semanas debe ir al hospital por su
atención y esperar como estamos viendo
además para que la sigan atendiendo
tiene que dar fe de vida siendo al banco
a cobrar su jubilación
la última vez que fue se enfermó porque
hacía mucho frío y ahora está esperando
que venga la policía para que dé fe de
que ella está viva
qué nos está pasando dónde quedó la
dignidad de amalia mejor dicho donde
quedó la dignidad de todos nosotros que
nos la pasamos haciendo trámites
engorrosos que nos llevan a peregrinar
de cola en cola para lograr obtener
algún trámite algún certificado algo que
nos acredite
y nos fuimos acostumbrando a vivir las
cosas de esta manera hacer colas el
sistema se cayó vuelva mañana necesita
otro certificado lo tiene que ir a
sellar demuestre me que usted es usted
y finalmente terminamos acostumbrando
viviendo esta pesadilla burocrática
pero hay buenas noticias no todo tiene
que ser así oyeron hablar de estonia
esto ya es el país más digital del mundo
en este momento
es tan digital que solamente tres cosas
requieren ir físicamente a una oficina
casarse divorciarse y hacer la
separación de bienes
conocí a estonia por primera vez en 2007
y descubrió un país que había logrado
transformar su burocracia y hacer
realmente fácil la vida de sus
ciudadanos
el caso es que cuando esto ya se
independiza de la unión soviética estaba
tan quebrada que tuvo que innovar y
transformar su burocracia con un nuevo
diseño pensado en el ciudadano
a eso yo lo llamo el ciudadano digital
y qué es esto del ciudadano digital es
usar los datos del ciudadano de forma
transparente segura y confidencial para
darnos a todos el derecho de un trato
justo e igualitario
y esto lo logran resolviendo cuatro
cosas
nos piden lo mismo a todos seguimos los
mismos pasos nos atienden las personas
correctas y toda esa información se
guarda para control posterior en todo el
mundo se están haciendo grandes
esfuerzos para mejorar estas piezas de
la burocracia
expedientes digitales trámites online y
así todo el mundo cree que está
siguiendo los pasos de toña pero lamento
decirles que no están así
esto ya sigue un camino totalmente
diferente y casi opuesto a lo que se
está haciendo en todo el mundo
y vamos a compartir en este momento
algunas de las cosas que yo aprendí del
trabajo que ellos hacen
los ciudadanos de estonia jamás tienen
que volver a llevar una información al
estado más de una vez a esto le llaman
el principio ones only o una sola vez
imagínense no tener que llevar nunca más
la partida de nacimiento la fotocopia
del dni para hacer un trámite eso es
ones only y para hacer esto hacen algo
nuevo que es hacer que los sistemas se
hablen entre sí que se puedan hacer
preguntas y respuestas y de esta manera
evitar tener que hacer peregrinar al
ciudadano entre los distintos organismos
para que vayan a buscar esa información
para hacer esto de forma segura
confidencial han creado un software que
llaman x row este x road es como un
whatsapp de sistemas permite que un
sistema hable con otro le pida lo que
necesite y con esa información opere
acá lo que estamos viendo es el monitor
de los mensajes que se están produciendo
en este momento en españa hoy es sábado
son más o menos las 20 horas y los
sistemas se están trabajando
hay más de un millón de mensajes de
ínter mensajes de interconsultas entre
los sistemas por día
vamos a verlo un poquito más funcionando
cada círculo que están viendo es un
sistema un organismo y los rombos son
personas
vamos a ver funcionar ahora rápidamente
como los sistemas se empiezan a
comunicar y preguntar cosas y el ejemplo
que les traigo es de una persona que va
a retirar sus medicamentos a una
farmacia cuando va el sistema de la
farmacia le pregunta al sistema del
médico si en la receta está bien el
sistema del médico le pregunta al
sistema de la obra social por la
cobertura y si todo está bien entonces
se produce la operación y el médico el
paciente recibe el medicamento del
farmacéutico dos personas interactuando
muchos sistemas controlando acá no hay
posibilidad de falla no hay posibilidad
de error no hay posibilidad de fraude la
corrupción no está permitida no está
contemplada en esta forma de trabajo
fíjense con este pequeño con esta pieza
digital logran algo realmente muy fuerte
en menos de un segundo hecho que vieron
ustedes ahí tardó menos de un segundo en
menos de un segundo resolvieron dos de
las cosas que yo mencioné antes el trato
justo porque todos a todos les piden lo
mismo por un lado y por otro lado
tenemos que la información ha quedado
registrada y guardada
con ese modelo eliminamos la posibilidad
de tener que peregrinar dentro de
distintos organismos vamos a dar ahora
por las colas vamos a tratar de ver cómo
sacan las colas y para eso usan este
concepto de procesos proactivos opus
imagínense que nace un bebé el sistema
del médico habla con el sistema cuando
digo sistema hablando con sistemas no
hay personas son sistemas hablando con
sistemas el sistema del médico le dice
al sistema del registro civil hay un
nuevo ciudadano necesita un dni el
sistema del registro civil crea un dni
parece nuevo ciudadano pero su trabajo
no termina y sabe que se ayuda no
necesita una cobertura social entonces
avanza un paso habla con la obra social
y le dice necesitamos una cobertura para
este nuevo bebé mientras pasa todo esto
los padres están jugando con el bebé y
de esta forma los organismos se
adelantan un paso creando lo que a
nosotros nos lleva una cola
si bien es imposible hacer colas con
este mecanismo de trabajo entonces con
los con el principio wilson list y con
los procesos push logran resolver estas
cuatro cosas que hablábamos antes
pero acá no termina la historia porque a
veces ustedes podrán pensar bueno y si
quiero hacer algo que no está previsto
como hago lo primero que tienen que
hacer es no hacer cola porque ellos
tienen lo que se llama mi ventanilla
personal su ventanilla personal para que
cada uno pueda ahí realizar lo que
necesita acá vemos dos ejemplos de mi
ventanilla que como ven son diferentes
pero ambos permiten hacer absolutamente
todo con cualquiera de los dos yo puedo
entrar a ver mis datos o hacer trámites
con cualquiera de los organismos del
estado solamente tengo que elegir la que
más me gusta es como bajarse una
aplicación para el teléfono y si soy
programador hasta me puedo hacer la mía
no hay ningún problema
pero sigamos avanzando vamos al control
de uso de los datos
cuando un ciudadano de estonia ve que se
están usando sus datos porque tiene
capacidad para ver quién está prestando
datos a quién quién está viendo los
datos de quién y ve que algo no está
normal que algo no está pasando como
corresponde presiona un botón y se
genera una auditoría de lo que está
pasando así que es como un gran hermano
invertido es el ciudadano el que
controla qué se están haciendo con sus
datos qué está haciendo el estado con
sus datos
bueno después de todo esto usted debe
empezar que no sé para qué viene a
hablar porque esto es imposible se hace
en los países fríos porque allá no
tienen nada que hacer hace mucho frío y
realmente la cosa no es así
realmente la cosa no es así porque si
ustedes se están imaginando eso es
realmente porque sienten que esto va lo
que estamos haciendo acá va para otro
lado y les voy a decir que vamos al
gobierno digital para allá y ellos van
al ciudadano digital para allá es
totalmente opuesto y eso lo que quiero
transmitirles pero yo estoy acá hoy para
decirles que esto se puede hacer acá lo
hemos hecho acá lo estamos haciendo acá
en neuquén se está usando desde hace
varios años este modelo claro que
primero tuvimos que entender y
comprender estos principios que yo les
estoy contando tuvimos que adaptarlos
para poder adoptar los a nuestra cultura
y finalmente tuvimos que abrir un camino
nuevo de cómo aprovechar estas cosas en
2008 cuando empezamos
hasta hicimos un clon de ese famoso x
robes el whatsapp de sistemas que yo les
comenté con ese whatsapp pretendíamos
hacer lo mismo que hacen ellos evitar el
peregrinaje
pero mientras en esto ya con eso alcanzó
dijeron hagamos esto y todos hicieron
caso acá no pasó lo mismo acá cada uno
siguió haciendo la suya entonces tuvimos
que inventar piezas nuestras piezas que
no necesita españa para poder lograr el
mismo resultado
fíjense si yo logro que los sistemas se
hablen entre sí ya tenemos resuelto el
problema de un lado están los datos del
otro lado está el sistema que consulta
los datos del otro sistema la parte de
los datos es bastante fácil la parte de
que el sistema pregunte es más difícil y
acá se nos empezó a demorar eso cada día
era más lento el desarrollo de las
aplicaciones modificadas por lo tanto
decidimos que no podíamos esperar porque
hacer esperar a que todos cambiaran sus
sistemas para poder beneficiar al
ciudadano nos hacía esperar a terminar
todo para que el ciudadano se diera
cuenta entonces creamos un portal un
portal que es capaz de hablar con las
bases de datos de todos los sistemas y
de esta forma un funcionario cuando
alguien se presenta en una ventanilla
para en lugar de decirle tráiganme el
certificado de esto no directamente él
entra en este portal y puede consultar
en línea todas las bases de datos de
todos los organismos para saber si el
ciudadano que está ahí cumple o no con
los requisitos con este pequeño pieza
tecnológica latina neuquina pudimos
alcanzar en la misma performance
sin tener que resolver todos los
sistemas ya que viene una paradoja y
esto es lo que empieza a mostrar que no
es lo mismo lo que se está haciendo con
lo que ellos hicieron para hacer todo
esto no hace falta modificar los
sistemas actuales hace falta crear las
cosas que hoy nos están creando nos
están haciendo acá tenemos el ejemplo de
cómo se produce un certificado digital
virtual sin que el ciudadano tenga que
peregrinar nunca más papeles en la calle
nunca más llevar un certificado el
ciudadano recibe los beneficios
instantáneamente por supuesto en
paralelo y con otras velocidades y cada
uno a su tiempo va conectando sus
sistemas para no tener que usar ni
siquiera este portal veamos el impacto
en 2017 uno solo de estos trámites con
este truco latino ahorro 108 años
ciudadanos una vida por supuesto
repartida entre muchos verdad
y ahorramos también una columna de res
más de 200 metros de alto de papel
pero el mundo sigue avanzando estonia y
finlandia empezaron a trabajar juntos
esto ya creó el modelo finlandia lo
adoptó pero no es usar lo mismo eso que
yo les mostré antes de la farmacia una
persona que vive en estonia que se
atiende en un hospital de esto ya puede
ir a finlandia e ir a la farmacia y
retirar su medicamento como lo vimos
exactamente igual eso es lo que ellos
han logrado por supuesto cuando hacen
esto también liberan el código de ese
famoso x road y lo hacen libre para que
cualquiera lo puede usar hay muchos
países del mundo están probando los
azules lo están usando los rojos lo
están probando los amarillos están
estudiando si vale la pena los verdes
están operativos
neuquén como si fuera una pieza de un
lego
de un juego de lego cambio rápidamente
parte de lo que había hecho ese famoso
clon por el de estonia y hoy figuramos
entre los actores que están usando
operativamente el equipo
no me cabe ninguna duda que esto es
factible de hacer aquí tenemos la
experiencia local
tenemos las herramientas disponibles
tenemos una ruta transitada que nos
permite decir esto se puede hacer pero
tenemos algo mucho más importante ya
hace tiempo alguien un argentino había
escrito que esto era factible y ese fue
kim o que no nos muestra en esta imagen
lo que es la burocracia la famosa cola
de la burocracia
esta es la cola los ciudadanos haciendo
cola contra el gobierno y el en su poder
de síntesis demuestra que la solución
para la burocracia es dar vuelta a la
cola
bueno entonces ya tenemos antecedentes
tenemos historia tenemos que hacerlo no
hay más excusas
yo me comprometo realmente a seguir
avanzando para recuperar esta dignidad
perdida para que ni amalia ni ningún
argentino ni latinoamericano tenga que
seguir padeciendo esta burocracia que no
se merece
y yo les digo una le dejo una pregunta
cuando recuperen esta dignidad perdida y
ya no tengan que hacer más cola que van
a hacer con el tiempo libre gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]